[Music]
the [ __ ] call of duty video exists
you were just still searching for it
[ __ ] let me tell you something
i don't give up okay bro it's cause it's
age restricted yeah all right
i'm watching on my phone
[Music]
damn it's going to take me a few times
really to really absorb that
like i sent that to cash and he's like
okay are we
are we actually broken from this
is this actually funny i'm like bro this
is advanced like a single image
conveying a point in the middle of a
video edit like this comment like
literally had me crying it was like
explain this to someone who's 82.
dude kelsey showed me this tweet today
and it was this a picture of a printed
out okay it was basically this girl her
mom wanted to send her a picture that
was on her phone so she photocopied her
phone screen and then printed it out and
mailed it to her imagine describing this
to her
is this real life oh it's a video game
what's that yeah starting with the base
layer of explaining call of duty and
then having to explain getting dunked on
and she's like so why why is it passing
gas
because that's just funny why is that
little boy staring at the wall do you
know him do you know that little boy no
i don't it's a
it's like a stock image i see stalk
image this is what brain rot sounds like
and now for something completely
different judge rules paul flores and
father to stand trial and dang well i
just thought this was interesting
because it happened literally the week
after i talked about this it had been
like a year since i listened to that i
don't know i listened to it in like
april oh
bro
holy [ __ ] oh my god i'm about to blow
your [ __ ] mind oh dude i just had
like 72 layers of acid hit my brain
this dude
holy [ __ ]
he
okay
[ __ ] me and elena worked with this fool
at
no way bro he's wearing
a t-shirt from one of the corporate
events that they do this [ __ ] went like
like stupid with all the employees like
yo that guy what did you do with him
okay i never personally interacted with
him but like maybe i had seen him around
like
his name was really familiar i like see
his name on emails and stuff that whole
time
we just had a [ __ ] serial killer
working in the building oh he was in the
building bro he was like there like what
yeah oh man they just hit me like a
freight train i'm like why do i know
that name and wait nobody in the company
was like yo this guy's got a pretty
sketchy history no no because they knew
like there was tons of people that knew
that he was probably the guy that did it
definitely the guy that did it oh he
just didn't have enough evidence to take
him in maybe not like i don't know what
the hiring process was with him i think
he had been there a while what did he do
uh i want to say he was like some like
facilities type employee
which is like so sketchy yeah so this is
just interesting because it happened
literally last week remember there's
enough evidence to try both of them
elena brought this up to me the day he
got arrested because this image was
circulating and people from were just
like
yo this is
[ __ ] now it's really starting to like
you should listen you should listen to
the podcast i mean this guy's like a
gigantic piece of [ __ ]
come and now uh on gabby potato's case
dog the bounty hunter is searching for
the [ __ ]
for brian laundry no whoever's hiding
brian laundry just give it up dude it's
kind of funny because like i guess dog
the bounty hunter found some hot lead
yesterday and now he's like searching oh
yeah [ __ ] you think he's a [ __ ]
i don't know i watched some interview
with him and i'm like this guy seems
kind of smart actually i say [ __ ]
because it's just he's a public person
and i feel like all his movements will
now be
written about because all these news
organizations just want to
milk this [ __ ] for all it's worth so
anything he says and does it's just
gonna be broadcasted i was thinking
about that there's no reason why he
wouldn't just be on this twitter feed
right now watching every single update
being like oh well they found me i'm
gonna go to the next place yeah
something what if he does find him
though i mean that'd be some [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] world are we living in
i mean he's the guy that that brings
this dude out by his [ __ ] shirt
you know just yeah forest dog the bounty
hunter emerges
i mean i agreeing this kid i think like
you know all the discussion about all
the
you know like the indigenous people and
random children from like
you know like other communities it's
crazy how many people just go missing
all the time yeah you know and they
don't have the benefit of being a
youtuber
you know they're just like regular
people
it's it's just it's it just blows my
[ __ ] mind that human like that
there's such a large percentage of
humans that are wired to just be like
yeah i'm gonna take a person now if dog
the bounty hunter finds this dude like
police are just gonna look the worst
they ever have
i know and here's the thing too is that
he's following the law and that every
every like lead he gets and everything
every lead he like generates himself he
has to report that to the authorities
right he's like everything he's finding
out he's telling them and then he's just
gonna go look for himself
so like if they have the same
information that he does and he still
beats them too
to him i mean yeah
absurd you know you know what's messed
up to me is
the county that reported
you know that the the lesbian couple
that was murdered being unrelated to
brian laundry
i all i think about all these
documentaries where
it comes out like 30 years later that
the commissioner or whatever at that
time
didn't want to deal with bad pr so they
just negated the the possibility of a
connection to like save face
and so when they like immediately ruled
that out so quickly
you know
i don't know the details but i just
wonder in the back of my head oh
was that another one of those instances
and in 20 years we'll find out no yeah
they're actually related yep but dang
yeah if dog is letting them cheat off of
his homework and he finds him first
embarrassing man
a reality did you ever watch his show
no i never watched it
no i just know he's like a
psycho then you get showed up by a
couple guys wearing leather you know
that's i know that's bad you guys have
infrared cameras on helicopters and this
dude is cruising around the forest with
long bleach blonde hair and all his
vehicles and stuff are like branded
aren't they like blasting music yeah
doesn't have like his face wrapped on
one of the trucks
blasting kid rock so yeah so he says
that he says that he found a campsite
that brian laundry was at uh
from september 1st to 3rd and then
september 6th the 8th i saw some article
on those being promoted on twitter like
why we're hardwired to care about the
murder it's like shut up man first of
all you know netflix is mad as [ __ ] that
the internet solved this no they're
already working they're probably already
working on on like a post documentary
mark my words man hulu and netflix are
gonna start lobbying like they're going
to lobby for like facebook groups to be
taken down so people can't talk to each
other and yeah
they're just going to start making their
own crimes
it's [ __ ] up they're just like making
them up not making them in real life
no no making them real life